quick shout out with kanye west
it came out that he's the richest man in
the world 6.6 billion richest black
richest black man in america
in america yes 6.6 billion then it came
back and they said forbes king came back
and said well it's not really 6.6
billion
it's 1.8 billion uh robert smith is
really still the richest black man in
america at 6 billion
vista equities then the nigerian aliko
is worth 11.8 billion but the reality is
the yeezy brand is valued at 3.2 to 4.7
billion dollars let me say that one more
time
the yeezy brand is valued at 3.2
to 4.7 billion dollars you know the
other day he announced his shoes at 200
you know it sold out by 7 a.m fully sold
by 7am can you imagine how crazy that is
people bought the shoes and flipped it
for 400 the same day on ebay
okay so what do you think about what
kanye's got going on okay this is a
really
really fascinating story i think the
person that's probably offended the most
is jay-z
is as hard as he's worked how many
different things he's involved
in and to think that he has to look up
to kanye west on on wealth i guarantee
you this is pissing off
jay-z in a big way i also find it also
very ironic that
he has elevated himself allegedly to
being the most
wealthiest or the richest black person
in america from
shoes right that he's had for what seven
eight years and michael jordan has built
a much bigger brand with shoes owns an
nba team and he has passed him up that
quickly by the way
michael is nike yeezy is adidas
and gap now that was a brilliant move
putting their shoes into gap and getting
kids exposed to it young
so now if you peel back a little bit
here there's some smoke and mirrors
going on with this stuff because
i think it was bloomberg first that
reported this story and then forbes
carved it up and chopped it up and said
it's complete bs you're not worth 6.6
billion so
remember what happened with kylie jenner
right when forbes put her on the cover
as being the first or the youngest
self-made billionaire
in the world right and then it came out
a little bit later that maybe
kris kardashian had been fudging some of
that and they felt that they got used a
little bit
so forbes is incredibly pissed off i
think at the kardashian family
even though kanye is exiting it you know
eventually here
i think this has something to do with a
little bit payback you know to go back
there and look at that story and try to
discredit it
because of how they were burned with the
kardashian number in the past so
i think there's some of that with forbes
involved here and bloomberg and forbes
you look at as the bible as the gospel
when it comes to personal wealth like
that
they've got a cottage industry of
ranking the richest people in the world
but
this has got so many layers it's
fascinating it's the kardashians
it's shoes it's nike it's rich it's
adidas
but i think there's something to be said
about a personal battle between
forbes and kris kardashian and the
extension of her and that family
you're into this story yeah i just find
it really loud
ups and downs and curves um
with kanye i'm not saying she's a gold
digger but
shame missing with a broke socialist
uncapitalist type of person i mean
when's the last time you shop at the gap
the fact that he's
bringing the gap to relevancy next thing
you know he might do a deal with
abercrombie and fitch i feel like it's
the 90s again
but uh obviously a brilliant dude um
polarizing guy and go get your money
kanye obviously he's single now
so i don't think he's going to have a um
a shortage of
suitors it's kind of a semi-genius would
you put him as a semi-genius yeah
yeah personally i would just with his
creativity you know
i mean he is he owns that brand 100 he
owns the whole thing
and he's got final say on all creative
decisions so i think he is a genius
to come up with a brand that sells like
that now we don't know what the volume
is right they might produce a pretty low
number so it does sell out
rather quickly which i'm sure is the
case but he is a genius he's created
this
i think he's got um
confidence of the highest magnitude that
even
like most people are like oh you're
crazy bro he's like yeah i am
that's right and he just embraces the
craziness and
i mean he's been he's been to he's got
mental anxiety and you know all sorts of
stuff going on
but yeah i think you know musically
music sick his ideas uh you can't tie
that guy down i mean
kim who never who knows what happened
with that by the way i think
i i think kanye uh is battling with
something right now
this my opinion okay i tell you what
he's battling with right now tell us
i think he's battling with what has he
experienced today
so think about it here's a guy that's
produced some of the greatest
hip-hop you know songs he's crushed
incredible albums where the world would
listen to it
he has done well as an entrepreneur he's
married to modern-day marilyn monroe
whether you're like her or not
kim kardashian is the modern day i don't
know who you put ahead of her as a
marilyn monroe we've talked about this
before
so at what level hasn't he reached who
has he partied with who
hasn't he partied with he's been to the
trump he's been to the white house he's
met presidents he's met prime minister
he's done everything right i think he's
at a point right now where for him the
battle is do i continue being this
famous powerful person making money
making products
or do i go after purpose i think this
guy can really
have a massive impact in the world with
how he himself grew as an individual and
i don't know what's going to happen with
that
but i own a domain called kanyakan okay
i bought for him kanye khan that i would
love for kanye to be a guest on the
podcast even here or on valuetainment to
interview him
because there are some questions i want
to ask him that no one's ever asked and
i'd like to be able to ask that of him
and i want to kind of go deeper on the
way he processes issues and how he views
certain things but in order to get that
domain i'd love to have a sit down with
him anybody who knows
how to get a hold of this man i'd love
to have a meeting
with i would love that kanye i think the
world
would appreciate i don't think the right
interview with him has been done yet i
don't think the right interview has been
done with him yet he's been on a lot of
different platforms
but the right interview has been done
with i once won nine dollars from kai
okay was it nine dollars or a dollar i
don't know what ten dollars what was the
number
nine dollars i won nine dollars ten
dollars no nine nine dollars yeah kai
loves giving me money like i wouldn't
bet
i love he's giving me money it's just a
threshold
no but that wasn't a bet that was if i
say it that's not a bet i never said i'm
betting you so it's a
was that the joe rogan yeah joe rogan he
thought it was going to be bigger than
elon musk i said i don't know about that
i just think kanye needs uh oh and joe
did a good job with that interview i
just think i have philosophical
questions for this guy
not just entertaining questions yeah i
want to go deeper like he's probably
want to be challenged too by that
yeah i want that kind of a conversation
with the but listen more power to him
um you brought up the purpose um with
kanye i mean
you've clearly seen some sort of shift
over the last
few years with kanye that it was all
music and then it turned into fashion
and over the last
really couple years it's been church and
politics
and you know he used to you know come
from chicago and
and doing his thing with jay-z in new
york and
you know in the studio doing his thing
now he's living on a freaking ranch in
wyoming
and he's doing sunday churches and
kanye's sunday service and
obviously he was running for president
major air quotes going on there if
you're listening just
audio um i think he's finding his
purpose and i think
i don't think he's joking wrong when he
says he's running for president by the
way i think he's that sick in the head
he think he could actually he's not sick
in the head i don't think he's sick in
the head i think he's that much driven
by purpose yeah i don't mean sick in the
head in the negative way but like
crazy enough okay yeah here's the other
thing once he aligned with
god you know having his sunday services
and he supported trump and he wore the
maga hat you know
he got turned on by the mainstream media
so they're throwing out there that
that you know bipolar depression that
you know all the mental
aspects of is he crazy this kind of
thing yeah he's crazy rich that's what
he is
and i think he's really toying with the
media exactly how he wants to
um i would imagine and you can already
tell that it's going to be at least on
paper or at least the way it looks is
going to be an amicable divorce
with kim i mean it looks like you know
with that many kids involved and that
much money that they're going to get
through this thing
pretty uh you know peacefully so yeah i
think i think the media now because
of where he's aligned himself you know
just with his christian values
and the fact that politically he's not
just buying into everything that the
left
wants him to he's going to be targeted
and he's going to be painted as kind of
a villain
so you got to like read through some of
these headlines in mainstream media
yeah i mean wish him all the best are
you a kanye west fan
i've uh yeah i would say i've always
been uh uh and jennifer's always
jennifer all with you you know he's a
very talented guy
i i've watched mo i watch every one of
his interviews whether he did the ellen
degeneres one where he stood up and
people like what the hell is wrong with
this guy whether it's the
big boy interview whether it's the elon
musk interview i just like the way this
guy thinks
i think people like that have to prop
have to be properly interviewed on the
way they process
issues i think the world can learn from
that that and by the way i think elon
musk also
uh is another guy that uh we have to get
deeper
on the way he thinks there's a there's a
there's a chippy side
to them where it's like you know you
poke and it's like then the magic comes
out like i think there's
anyways i think there's a there's a part
where they need to be interviewed
uh specifically with connie so i'm
curious to know what's gonna happen with
that and every time there's an interview
out there i just
enjoy every single one of them because
the guys are fascinating so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]